bueno
[Música]
no
bueno
[Música]
ellos son café vil chris sacca patricia
y leo y ven que todos tienen algo en
común verdad
son deportistas
la vida a través de un deporte que me
transformó tanto como profesional y como
persona me permitió descubrir y entrenar
otras capacidades
la resiliencia y la empatía resiliencia
es la capacidad para poder adaptarse
positivamente a situaciones adversas
empatía la capacidad de poder compartir
y percibir lo que el otro puede sentir
estas son dos capacidades que nos faltan
en mi planificación deportiva
y se preguntarán cómo las entrenamos es
una tarea que se entrena todos los días
en donde toman relevancia el compromiso
el esfuerzo la motivación la constancia
y la pasión desde lo más simple de la
cotidianeidad a lo más complejo que se
nos puede presentar en el ámbito de lo
deportivo
desde pequeña conocí un deporte que fue
el motor de mi vida el voley iba a la
plaza a la arena a la vereda de mi
edificio a todo el lugar donde pudiera
correr y no se me pinchaba la pelota era
bastante intensa
la protagonista de esta aventura era mi
pelota blanca el caprichito que me había
regalado mi abuelo coco un sábado a la
mañana de la góndola de juegos de un
súper
todos los jueves y sábados y vamos a ver
los partidos de la liga argentina de
vóleibol de un club de mi ciudad soñando
con la idea de que algún día pudiera
jugar en ese club
tan solo tenía nueve años cuando leí la
frase en una publicidad de ese mismo
club que decía si los sueños no te
alcanzan alcanzarlos vos
recitando a tantos años como si fuese un
mantra y tal vez sin dimensionar el
poder de esas palabras y sé que mi vida
transcurriera con esa filosofía
durante mucho tiempo de llevarla
caprichito para todos lados pude
comenzar a entrenar en el club que tanto
soñaba a ese día lo registró como uno de
los días más felices de mi vida porque
había logrado concretar mi primer gran
sueño
cuántos de ustedes tienen sueños porque
la vida es la concreción constante de
sueños y de aprendizajes es por eso que
luego de concretar el que tanto deseaba
que era comenzar a jugar en el club se
despertó en mí otra idea
el ser profe de educación física con la
famosa y tan conocida frase cuando sea
grande repetía desde el último grado de
la escuela primaria cuando sea grande
quiero ser profe de educación física y
entrenadora de voley
a los 16 años luego de una lesión que me
impidió seguir compitiendo y entrenando
por muchos meses la concreción de ese
objetivo cambió de rumbo
en ese momento tenía dos opciones o
quedarme enojada y frustrada con la vida
porque no sabía ni cómo ni cuándo iba a
poder volver a jugar ni cuánto tiempo me
iba a llevar y la otra opción era ir en
busca de ese sueño que quería cumplir
cuando fuese grande
ese mismo año se me abrieron las puertas
de un instituto de formación docente
destinado a la preparación física y el
entrenamiento todos los lunes llegaba
con el uniforme de la secundaria y en el
baño me disfrazaba de profe
desde ese día nunca me detuve conocí
otra versión de mí misma una versión que
luego de algo que me generó dolor me
permitió explorar y conocer algo nuevo
que también me hacía feliz en ese
momento era la resiliencia lo que me
estaba permitiendo crecer
fueron pasando los años y muchos libros
de entrenamiento por medio y descubrí
que había algo más que me movilizaba la
discapacidad
llega el año 2016 y con él los juegos
olímpicos y paralímpicos de río 2016
durante muchos años preparándome fue
felizmente convocada como voluntaria de
los juegos olímpicos que era algo nuevo
por alcanzar
durante cuatro años lo ideal y se lo
pensé y lo viví en mi cabeza y vendí más
de 600 docenas de empanadas con el
repudio de la tía tula
pero el destino hizo que fuese diferente
parece así que luego de una gran
tristeza y de avisarme 20 días antes del
comienzo del olímpico que me habían
dejado afuera por recorte de personal se
producía otro golpe del destino como
aquella lesión
a los siete días llegó una carta
la carta que me invitaba a trabajar a
los juegos paralímpicos
y el destino me estaba preparando para
algo gigante
a las pocas semanas de haber sido
convocada comencé a trabajar en
distintos en distintos deportes
adaptados e instituciones de mi ciudad y
me empapé de aprendizajes a los 20 años
conocí lo que es la máxima expresión de
excelencia en deportes adaptados y
también disfrute de conocer a los
máximos referentes de cada país que eran
deportistas con discapacidad es allí
donde entendí que las capacidades más
importantes para acompañar el desarrollo
de nuestros deportistas eran la
resiliencia y la empatía puede ser muy
veloz muy fuerte muy flexible pero un
entrenador que apueste a vos en el
desarrollo de la empatía y la
resiliencia te convierte en alguien
invencible y eso es lo que hago hoy con
mis deportistas
dos días antes de finalizar el
paralímpico estando en mi lugar de
trabajo la villa paralímpica tomando
mates con uno de los referentes de
nuestro país me pregunta facebook de qué
deporte venís
y ahí me entregó una tarjeta que tenía
el nombre y teléfono de una profesora
laura comentó que me iba a permitir
combinar mi vieja pasión el voley con la
nueva que estaba descubriendo la
discapacidad
termino mi jornada laboral vuelvo al
departamento donde estaba viviendo
voy a buscar mi tarjeta no la tenía la
había perdido
pensé ya fue por algo la perdí por algo
no tenía que pasar esto seguí mi día
y al día siguiente vuelvo a la villa
estábamos prontos de finalizar ya el
paralímpico entró a la habitación donde
guardaba mi bolso cada mañana y ahí
estaba la tarjeta tirada en el piso
doy fe a través de mi experiencia y la
intensidad con la que lo vivo que los
sueños se transforman que buscan nuevos
caminos que te llevan aprendizajes
extremos siempre y cuando uno esté
abierto a eso nuevo por aprender
volví de río
y comencé a planificar el parábola y en
mi ciudad voley adaptado para personas
con discapacidad motriz
qué es lo que veo en ellos
jugadores de parábola y tres años
después camino junto a estas personas
los deportistas del para voley hoy los
protagonistas de mi día a día con los
cuales comparto charlas mates con los
que aprendo a aumentar mi capacidad
resiliente y a luchar siempre desde el
lugar de uno para generar mayor empatía
apuesto a formar deportistas que me
generan reflexionar sobre la vida
recibo a personas que nunca hicieron un
deporte y que a partir del parábola y
sienten esa liberación que solo la
práctica de algo que te genera placer te
puede brindar
personas que jamás pensaron que iban a
poder volver a hacer algo y hoy
representan la celeste y blanca en el
seleccionado nacional que sufran que
luchan y que viven intensamente ese
momento del encuentro que disfrutamos
del para voley
y lo disfrutamos juntos y mucho ser
entrenadora no es tarea fácil pero ser
entrenadora de un deporte adoptado para
mí es una tarea extraordinaria
nosotros tenemos el golpe arriba el
saque el bloqueo el remate y una fuerza
necesaria para no detenernos jamás a
pesar de cualquier adversidad
una vez por mes nos vamos de viaje
generamos un trabajo en equipo
inigualable con pasos cortos pero muy
firmes que dejan una huella permanente
tenemos las miles de fotos que nos
sacamos en cada rincón que visitamos
tenemos las camisetas la rodillera las
vendas y la energía de estar en
movimiento
también tenemos la amistad que
construimos con cada entrenador y
jugador del resto del país
les propongo que en sus vidas busquen
ese golpe de arriba ese remate y esa
fuerza necesaria para alcanzar sus
sueños gracias
[Música]